[Musique]
bonjour origines et là bonjour alan
ivory et bonjour aux auditeurs de
martine une première qui nous écoutent
vous est conseillé avec les cultivent de
la 7e mais vous étiez également co
directrice de campagne du député du sud
jean flics ni l'or alors vous savez quel
groupe a rejoint jean philippe meylan
alors d'abord permettez moi de remercier
les près de quinze mille électeurs qui
ont porté leurs suffrages sur la
candidature de jean philippe nylon et
surtout remercier tous ceux qui ont pris
part à cette campagne les militants les
sympathisants et tous ceux qui se sont
manifestés pour apporter leur soutien à
la campagne de jean philippe nylon qui
était aussi co dirigé par d'autres
directeurs de campagne fallait à l'osa
françois ce carreau et lucien adnot élus
du mime alors sauvé il a rejoint le
groupe communiste c'est ça ce que je
crois que comprendre alors sur la
question de l'appartenance au groupe jeu
moins que les discussions sont encore en
cours puisqu'il y a eu la proposition de
constitution d'un groupe outremer
je crois qu'il faut qui a été abandonnée
ne semble donc pas non si elle en est
sûre alors c'est vrai que certains
s'était proposé de rejoindre ce groupe
ont abandonné cette idée
d'autres lots rejeté dès le départ et
donc il est vrai que les les potentiels
la potentielle réalisation
concrétisation de cette de cette idée
est aujourd'hui bon c'est très compromis
quant aux mesures que sa panda donc
ça ne savait pas encore s'il a rejoint
le groupe parce que moi ce que j'ai vu
crise et qu'il avait rejoint le groupe
communiste
les facilités dans lors de la précédente
mandature dans le groupe gdr avec les
communistes d'ailleurs avec mars et
alors ce qui fait ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est d'abord que cette première idée de
constitution de ce groupe est déjà un
symbole fort j'espère que c'est le signe
de la volonté de travailler au delà des
intérêts particuliers
un territoire ou un autre la volonté de
travailler ensemble et de transcender
les intérêts particuliers
c'est une idée aussi qui avait été émise
par jean-philippe ils ont au cours de
cette campagne
vraisemblablement il devrait
effectivement si cette idée n'aboutit
pas à rejoindre le groupe gdr au sein
duquel il a pu travailler aux côtés de
bruno nestor azérot et de alfred
marie-jeanne sous l'ancienne mandature
et les choses se sont relativement bien
passé donc il n'y a pas de raison qu'il
ne rejoigne pas ce groupe si l'idée de
groupe outremer ne se concrétise
alors si si on devait faire un bilan de
la campagne ce sera un bilan pour vous
positif c'est un bilan positif très
satisfaisant la campagne a été belle
elle a été longue elle a été exaltée et
je crois que les résultats ont été au
rendez vous malgré le soutien affiché
d'alfred marie jeanne qui n'est pas
venue faire campagne
je répète qu alfred marie jeanne a très
tôt annoncé qu'il ferait campagne
essentiellement dans le centre et à fort
de france où les enjeux est très
important et où la campagne a été très
difficile et les résultats l'ont
démontré heureusement qu alfred
marie-jeanne s'était concentrée sur ces
deux circonscriptions notamment quant au
sud
la campagne a été menée avec le mime et
l'ensemble des élus du mime qui ont
soutenu la candidature de jean philippe
nylon et même au delà
les alliés de du grand semblait et
notamment le rdr qui ont pris part à
cette campagne très active vous
personnellement comment vous l'avez vécu
cette campagne en tant que jeune
militante du
du mime sétif première campagne des
législatives ça a été effectivement ma
première campagne des législatives à la
direction
maintenant ça n'a pas été ma première
campagne puisque j'ai mené campagne aux
municipales à ducos aux côtés de gens
ont commencé à l'époque soutenu par le
mime maintenant c'était ça a été une
campagne assez l'aude assez éprouvante
mais vraiment très positive il y a eu de
nombreux militants de nombreuses
présence au meeting qui ont été
organisées alors qu'on pouvait
considérer que les conférences en tant
que telle était peut-être passé de mode
et on a vu au contraire un regain
d'intérêt pour les conférences de jean
philippe muller par exemple est ce que
pour le grime cette élection n'est pas
négatif de patrick hâtive pardon est ce
que le bilan pardon n'est pas plutôt
négatif parce qu'on passe de deux
députés à un seul on ne peut pas dire
que ce soit une réussite
mais dans la mesure où il n'y avait
qu'un candidat mime
je crois que c'est 100 % de réussite
puisque le candidat mime a remporté
brillamment ces élections maintenant le
choix de départ qui avait été fait à
savoir qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul candidat
forcément compromettait les possibilité
d'envisager davantage de réussite
louis d'avoir plus de candidats mais je
ne sais pas si on aurait dû en avoir
plus c'est vrai que c'est une volonté
qui a été marquée par un certain nombre
de militants assez nombreux ce n'est pas
le choix qui a été retenu je crois qu'il
faut tout simplement en prendre en
prendre acte et savourer la belle
victoire de jean philippe ne l'ont tout
simplement on va pas refaire l'histoire
il faut peut-être pas s'est passé entre
le recul quand même avec le recul quand
vous regardez les résultats
pardon sur la circonscription
perdus et celle du centre atlantique
vous avez des regrets parce que j'étais
un moment pressenti pour mener la
bataille sur cette circonscription parce
que vous avez des regrets et j'ai été
pressenti le choix d'une candidature
d'origine elle a été voulue par un
certain nombre de militants qui l'ont
exprimé maintenant à mon niveau je n'ai
jamais exprimé une volonté d'être
candidat parce que je ne suis pas dans
une démarche personnelle ça je l' ai
toujours dit et répété aujourd'hui les
résultats sont ce qu'ils sont tous à
tout simplement est-ce que ou paca dicko
6 mondial esata qui font leurs bagages
mon pape ni pour habitude denis roy gré
n'ya dans la vie personnelle mais
personnel - n'y a dans la vie politique
en copie ça dans la vie politique
j'ai toujours dit un sac et pollari
vient pas cacher donc moi je crois très
fermement à cela et donc il y aura
d'autres échéances
je suis encore jeune j'ai le temps de
voir venir
et puis il ne s'agit pas de se lancer
dans des élections pour se lancer dans
des élections il faut savoir peser le
pour et le contre
analyser la situation et voir aussi
quels effets négatifs et pervers
pourrait avoir l'affirmation d'une
ambition personnelle
or je ne suis absolument pas dans cette
démarche et je crois que ce n'est pas ce
que la population attend de ses élus
logistique ne se résume pas à des
considérations électoralistes
est-ce que moment
avec au regard des résultats réalisés
par le grand ensemble et donc aussi par
le mime est ce que votre parti ne fout
pas un moment leurs pensées un moment
revoir sa tête revoir sa conception la
conception du mouvement pour le rendre
plus dynamique mais je crois que c'est
un parti qui a déjà fait preuve aussi de
son de son dynamisme et qui a fait
preuve aussi de sa longévité
c'est un parti qui fonctionne de manière
régulière avec des instances qui se
réunissent des militants qui sont
nombreux je crois que c'est un parti qui
est extrêmement structuré et qui est
toujours prêt à partir à la bataille des
élections et on l'a vu dans le sud
maintenant il y à un renouvellement qui
s'instaure tout naturellement avec de
nouveaux militants qui nous rejoignent
le parti et à l'occasion de ces
élections on a pu aussi le voir des deux
des participants des membres de comités
patriotes qui sont et qui ont été bel et
bien présent et de nouvelles figures
donc non je crois qu'il faut conserver
le socle ce qui fonctionne et puis
toujours s'améliorer et ce qui est vrai
pour le mime est vrai pour l'ensemble
des parties en martinique et au delà
pour terminer nous allons parler donc de
la 7e l'heure est au bilan puisque de
l'année 2016 puisque il ya une plénière
aujourd'hui un la première année donc
deux mandatures exane est pas être
examiné en plénière donc ce matin le
compte administratif
quel bilan tirez-vous de ce
premier à globalement vous
et certains disent que la sit in a mis
la martinique à la règle non je crois
qu'il faut sortir de cela maintenant
certainement qu'il faudrait améliorer la
communication autour des actions faites
par la collectivité territoriale de
matinée avoir l'humilité de se le dire
mais je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire
objectivement que là que la martinique
est à l'arrêt la ctn a hérité d'une
situation particulièrement complexe
puisqu'il a fallu quand même
harmoniser fusionner l'ex conseil
général et l'ex conseil régional donc ce
n'est pas simple avec tout ce que ça
implique notamment au niveau humain et
puis une situation particulièrement
difficile au niveau aussi des finances
en ce qui me concerne en tant que
conseillère exécutive en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
je crois pouvoir tirer un bilan plutôt
satisfaisant de cette de cette première
année de mandature notamment sur les
questions d aide aux étudiants qui ont
été dont le traitement a été accélérée
et améliorée avec 80% près de 80% des
aides non remboursables
mandatée à jambe en janvier 2010 est
maintenant il faut aller encore plus
loin avec aussi la mise en place de
nouvelles formations que nous avons
appuyé je pense notamment aux deux iteka
carrières sociales à l'université ou à
d'autres bts dans des dans l'île dans
les lycées je crois que c'est un bilan
approfondi et qui est pour le moins
satisfaisant
auryn il est là je vous remercie c'est
terminé bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes et a61 les niveaux me mets à
6 aux habituels
la tête